the ps5 will be swapping some button
functions in japan
that might cause some confusion
cyberpunk 2077 has
officially gone gold and need for speed
hot pursuit
is getting a remaster i'm persia and
this is your save state for monday
october 5th
[Music]
if you live in the west then you're
probably used to using x to confirm and
circle to cancel when you're playing on
your playstation
but in japan it's the other way around
however all of that is about to change
when it comes to the ps5
their buttons will now also be x to
confirm and circle to cancel
i run into this issue all the time just
from hopping between my switch and my
ps4
where my muscle memory is just all mixed
up this is likely going to be the case
for many users in japan but a million
times worse
as this change comes to the playstation
after 26
very long muscle training years where it
gets really complicated is that the
change in these button functions will
only apply to the ps5
user interface and not in the game some
playstation games in the past have given
players the option to customize the
functions but we'll have to wait and see
if that's going to be the case when the
next gen is here
speaking of you should check out our
show generation next if you want to stay
up to date on next gen news
as we get closer and closer to launch
day
after a few delays cyberpunk 2077 is
sticking to that november 19th release
date
and nothing really solidifies that more
than the game officially going
gold going gold refers to when the
game's final code is certified and
pressed to a disk
but that doesn't necessarily mean
development has finished as there will
likely be updates and patches
post-release
it seems someone has also already got
their hands on a boxed copy too
and leaked a physical map and other
items in the box
the map showed the watson region which
is one of the starting areas in night
city which makes the map look
pretty convincing cyberpunk 2077 comes
to ps4 xbox one and pc next month
but don't forget that ps5 and series x
and the s versions are in the works and
you'll even get a free upgrade
to your respective console when they
release
after 10 years need for speed hot
pursuit is getting
a remaster and it's also releasing in
november
the hot pursuit remaster is coming to
ps4 xbox one and pc on november 6
and then the switch on november 13th
it's also gonna be cross cross-play have
enhanced visuals and
include all of the dlc that means an
additional 6 hours of gameplay and 30
more challenges will be available
right from the start there was no word
on the game coming to next gen but
it might be available through backwards
compatibility
that's all for now but be sure to visit
our channel for even more awesome
content
whether you want to learn more about
cyberpunk lore or
reminisce on some really weird
playstation ads we've got you covered
see you tomorrow on your next save state
[Music]
peace
[Music]
you